if I could add one former teammate to  this build team who would I add I mean  come on everybody knows that question  man I would add my God Odell man and I  know we're like we got some of the best  receivers in the game it's just the type  of guy that he is and the type of energy  that he brings it's Odell Beckham you  know I don't really feel like that about  like a lot of people but like I get his  point of view I just feel like in a  different lifetime like we was like  brothers in the league like we grew up  and had success and had failures and had  to overcome it so we never know it might  happen you know I love to play GM  sometimes do we know that I think at the  end of it you know we we see Odell in a  great place